hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear another movie review
and because it's still july it's still
giallo july so we're going to be talking
about another giallo movie so let's talk
about the italian director luciano
ercoli hopefully i'm pronouncing that
sort of right
um he's probably not you know a
household name in the giallo genre in
the way that you know mario baba or
dario argento or even like sergio
martino are
but uh he did make i mean he did some
spaghetti westerns and stuff like that
but he did make um at least three pretty
well regarded uh giallo films one of
these was forbidden photos of a lady
above suspicion which i may or may not
get to later in the month
death walks at midnight
and the movie that we're going to be
discussing today which is called death
walks on high heels
so this movie came out in 1971
and was one of a bunch of uh
collaborations that luciano ercoli did
with his wife who is a spanish actress
by the name of nieves navarro i think
i'm pronouncing that correctly although
in this movie she's actually credited as
susan scott
this movie is also one of the last film
appearances of an american actor by the
name of frank wolfe who actually uh took
his own life later the same year that
this came out i believe it was in
december he actually like slashed his
own throat in a hotel room
sadly so i don't know if this was
actually his last film appearance
because i think they did release a
couple of movies posthumously that he
had made um but this is definitely one
of his last film appearances
now
death walks on high heels has a pretty
low body count at least as far as jello
movies go um only three people die in it
that i remember
at least one of the kills is pretty
gruesome the other one's not so much and
i will say too that it plays out a
little bit more like maybe like a heist
or an espionage type movie than a murder
mystery
but it does still kind of retain enough
of that uh giallo charm that we all love
so much uh that makes it a pretty
entertaining watch for you know fans of
the sub genre so the movie starts out
with a bang uh or actually more like a
stab
so there's this eye patch wearing dude
and he's kind of like acting shifty on a
train you can tell that he's kind of
like
up to something or whatever um but then
like somebody comes to the door of his
cabin and stabs him to death like the
guy that stabs him is this dude wearing
like a black ski mask or a balaclava
whatever they call it um and he has
these really really intense like bright
blue eyes which is weird because that
was also kind of a thing in all the
colors of the dark maybe maybe those
bright blue contact lenses were just
like all the rage in italy like in the
early 70s because it seems like there's
a lot of giallo movies that have like
the killer with these like bright bright
blue eyes that are like
contact lenses and they actually are
contact lenses in this too like they're
not supposed to be
the guy's eyes are not supposed to
naturally look like that which i'll get
into
so the guy the eye patchworm guy on the
train who got murdered uh we learned
later on was actually an international
jewel thief by the name of ernest
richard and the man who killed him was
actually looking for some diamonds uh
that he had let's call it liberated uh
during a recent robbery but the murderer
doesn't find the diamonds like he goes
all through his stuff and he can't find
them
so after this opening sequence then we
cut to paris where richard's daughter
who is a french exotic dancer named
nicole
is being hassled by the cops who have a
suspicion that
she might know where the stolen diamonds
got off to like maybe her dad like you
know pass them to her at some point or
whatever
so she tells them look i haven't heard
from my dad in ages we don't talk i
don't have no idea where the loot is
just leave me alone
um she's also like pretty indifferent to
the fact that like did her dad got
murdered
they're basically like yeah he got
murdered she's like man whatever you
know what i mean she's like she doesn't
even react at all which i think is like
kind of funny so nicole has this
boyfriend who i think lives with her
yeah i guess he's like so he's like a
living boyfriend his name is michelle
and he appears to have some insecurities
about
not having a job and having to rely on
nicole's stripper income
uh to pay for his excessive drinking
among other things but that's usually
what he's doing
she tells him that she doesn't mind uh
she loves him anyway but it's quite
clear that he feels very emasculated by
this situation and takes it out on
nicole by kind of being a dick to her
pretty much all the time which you know
that's kind of par for the course for
dudes and giallo movies they're all kind
of jerks so we get to there are several
like long sequences of nicole kind of
shaking her money maker you know at a
couple different performances i guess
she works at a couple different uh clubs
she's kind of like the main attraction
there uh the first of these i'm gonna
say problematic alert uh the first
performance
is
her uh it's very cringe-inducing where
she's covered in very dark spray tan
and she's wearing a wig that kind of
looks like a short afro like was kind of
in the style in the 1970s
and after this like she has kind of a
feather bow and she's like wiggling
around and whatnot and then like
afterward when she's in her dressing
room like michelle comes in there and
says to her
then i think this is a direct quote i
love when you're all black
that like
that like he's sensuously like take it
off like the all over black face like
with cold cream it's something else i
have to tell you but yeah so that's like
the first performance so yeah 70s
uh there's also like another one which
is like a lot less problematic where
she's just wearing this kind of like
gold headdress thing and like shimmying
around in a cage or something like that
so at both of these shows
we see that nicole evidently has a super
fan or a stalker you know depending on
how you look at it
he's this kind of distinguished looking
older dude
who does things like i mean he just kind
of sits there and leers i don't know if
he's really leering he just kind of like
looks at her like she's a big cupcake or
something like that and uh he's but he
does stuff like lets himself into her
dressing room like without when she's
not in there buys her big bouquets of
roses kind of gets all up in her face
when she's you know trying to live her
life or whatever he's a little bit
awkward and like a little bit
overbearing like you can tell that he's
trying to be like
trying to appeal to her by being like a
little bit oh i'm so harmless and
pitiful like type of thing
uh she does handle this pretty well uh
all things considered like i said it's
probably like it's an occupational
hazard i imagine so she's kind of gotten
used to it
also while all of that is going on
uh nicole is also getting a couple of
what at first appear to be like prank
phone calls in which a guy who's talking
through like a voice synthesizer thing
threatens her like at first she just
thinks it's some loser but like later on
it's obviously somebody that knows her
and knows who she is so again because
she's a stripper she probably gets this
kind of crap all the time uh you know
and she's kind of used to this [ __ ]
so she handles that like a pro as well
so that night after these performances
uh her boyfriend michelle gets drunk
again and starts an argument again about
how nicole's ass wiggling is paying his
way in the world and he's not like a big
fan of it so i was just like so get a
job i don't really know what's
preventing him
he kind of says a few times it's like i
can't get the job i want but i'm not
really sure like what job he wants
exactly and why he's having such a hard
time getting it but yeah but i don't
know like he just keeps taking it out on
her like i said
so they have a big fight he flounces off
to do lord knows what and then after he
leaves the scary uh bright blue-eyed
dude with the ski mask crawls in
nicole's apartment window
and he has like a straight razor and
he's like look i'm just gonna cut you to
[ __ ] pieces if you don't tell me
where the diamonds are so this is
obviously somebody that knows who she is
uh again she insists look i don't know
where the diamonds are i haven't like
talked to my dad nothing like that but
the guy is kind of like yeah you
absolutely do know where they are and if
you don't tell me like i'm gonna come
back here and just like cut you into
mince meat uh and that's you know so
he's like threatening her so obviously
nicole is terrified by this uh series of
events so she flees to wherever it was
that michelle holed up in like after his
little tantrum
and even though he doesn't believe her
about the potential murderer after her
telling her oh you must have dreamed it
thanks a lot man you know what i mean no
i didn't dream it but okay thanks thanks
for your support uh they basically just
like kiss and make up
however things are looking a little less
rosy the next morning nicole is going
through the medicine cabinet looking for
aspirin or whatever and she discovers a
pair of bright blue contact lenses in
the medicine cabinet
so convinced that these belong to
michelle and you know subsequently he's
she thinks that he must be the one
that's been like threatening her all
this time
she decides she needs to get the hell
out of paris like right now
so remember the dude like the super fan
that was like coming to see all her
strip shows she decides she's gonna
utilize this guy i think it i don't know
like maybe he's a sucker or something
like that but she just like kind of
wants a way out of town
so
you know and he's been mooning after her
so she's like okay well i'm just gonna
take this opportunity
so it turns out that he's a british
surgeon by the name of dr robert
matthews
and so nicole basically like comes up to
him was like hey i need to get out of
town you know calgon take me away and
he's just like okay can do
so they actually just jet off to london
she doesn't tell anybody where she's
going she doesn't tell michelle
obviously because she thinks he's you
know a potential murderer and i guess
she doesn't tell her
workplace or anything she's like okay
we're gonna go to london and then
there's kind of like a shopping montage
where uh where the doctor like buys her
all these sexy outfits and boots and
wigs she wears like a lot of wigs in
this uh like i said she's
you know the actress that plays nicole
is the director's wife and he put her in
a lot of movies you know because
obviously he thought she was hot which
she is uh so you know you get to see
like all of her boobies and like her
trying on different outfits and stuff
like that so it's very like european
vacation like that part of it so dr
matthews then installs her in this kind
of remote seaside cottage near a small
fishing village which is obviously
supposed to be in rural england uh but
actually looks more like italy because
it is but you know what are you gonna do
now the duck tells her that he's married
but that his wife won't divorce him and
also that his wife is the one with all
the money which seems to be something of
a recurring theme in this movie but he
reassures her that his wife whose name
is vanessa doesn't know anything about
this cottage so it's fine like you'll be
safe there
uh the town seems kind of like nice
enough but everybody in the town is kind
of weird and shady and every time like
nicole goes to the pub or like whatever
they're all like staring at her
suspiciously because they know that like
some weird [ __ ] is going on like between
her and the doctor he introduces her in
the town like as his wife but i think
everybody's just like yeah right you
know it's that kind of thing
so the shadiest [ __ ] of all
these shady [ __ ] is this guy
named hallerie who actually he has a
wooden hand i think but i thought that
doesn't really like i think they
mentioned that but i don't think it
factors like much into the plot later on
maybe they just said because like ooh
spooky i don't know but he has like a
wooden hand and he's the guy that looks
after the cottage when dr matthews is
not there
also
uh somebody is watching nicole get naked
in the cottage like through a telescope
so there's that though honestly i really
do
wish that women in giallo movies would
learn to close their [ __ ] blinds i
mean i'm not blaming the victim i'm just
saying it's like don't be prancing
around naked if you don't want people
like looking in the [ __ ] it's a giant
movie come on close your blinds so
elsewhere uh dr matthews has had to
travel back to the city back to london
to do some eye surgery on a guy named
smith
uh in what is actually a pretty squirmy
if you're like you know if you kind of
squirm like watching people [ __ ] around
with people's eyes yeah this one was a
little rubbed like nothing bad happens
but he's actually doing it actually
looks like
i mean it was making me really nervous
like for the actor on the receiving end
of it because you could tell that it's
like oh i got this i'm just gonna scrape
all this stuff like off your eyeball or
take off the [ __ ] cataract or
whatever the [ __ ] he was doing and it
looks like they're really doing it i
mean it's not special effects or
anything so i was like oh my god it's
like hopefully that guy doesn't sneeze
and just click right in his [ __ ]
eyeball yikes so after the surgery is
finished and smith is all bandaged up
like his eyes are all bandaged this
unknown individual wearing black
high-heeled boots kind of like pops into
the room and shoots dr matthews in the
chest and now he actually does end up
surviving like the the shot
but they don't really know who did it
because smith who obviously heard the
shot but couldn't see dick because his
eyes were all bandaged over
he tells police that he thought the
killer was either a very determined
woman like the way they were walking or
it was a man like kind of treading
heavily but wearing women's shoes
because he could tell what kind of shoes
it was now back at the fake english
cottage uh whoever has been spying on
nicole through the telescope
actually sees a woman dressed in like a
black long black coat like talking to
her nicole appears to know this person
like she you know she let her in like
willingly and everything like that but
the person you know with the telescope
can't tell who it is because there's
like a lamp in front of the woman's face
so the mysterious woman like actually
throws some money at nicole and then
leaves
and then nicole seems to get like really
upset like she lays down the couch or
whatever and then not too long after
this nicole actually ends up
disappearing now from this point forward
the plot thickens big time uh a couple
people turn up dead i'm not gonna say
who because it's spoiling it
and everybody in this town and a few
people outside of it seem to know a lot
more about these murders and the
diamonds than they're letting on
inexplicably michelle the boyfriend who
uh nicole just like picked up and left
without telling him he shows up in town
out of the blue i guess he's uh found
out where she's at he drinks a shitload
in the pub and then throws up on a cop
it was actually a really funny scene
well i guess like he's super drunk and
then like the cops want to question him
and so
the lead cop like gives him this
concoction with like coffee with like it
looks like he put lemon juice in it and
i guess it's like supposed to look at
ipecac or something so it's supposed to
like induce vomiting uh which it does
and so yeah he goes to like to the
window and barfs and there's like a cop
down there so he barbs on the cop's hat
but yeah so the cops um are suspicious
of just like oh you're the boyfriend and
you turn up all of a sudden and you know
so he's like a suspect also
also there's like a really weird scene
this is neither here nor there but
there's a really weird scene in which
the cops are questioning the owner of a
commercial ice house because there's
something to do with like ice and like
body and time of death and somebody like
trying to stall decomposition by like
soaking the or soaking like you know uh
putting ice on the body or whatever so
they go question this guy who owns a
commercial ice house and this guy is
like i see this a lot in like italian
movies from this era there's always like
not always but there's often like one
like
really like gay stereotype and so
that's this dude's role in this movie so
he's like so gay apparently that he
can't even like answer police questions
without saying he's just like sitting
with a rose like
yeah that's right you know it's like
he's just like sniffing a rose the whole
time just for no reason just because gay
that's what that's what gay men do i
guess they just like sit there and sniff
roses while cops are trying to ask a
question about who bought some ice or
something like that uh he even like
openly hits on the younger cop who's
like the assistant to the older grizzled
cop uh and the older cop just kind of
like takes and you start like yeah
that'll happen yeah we'll we'll let him
come by himself next time since you like
him so much and then he calls the guy he
goes good day senora and i'm just like
okay
whatever
70s you so crazy now as i mentioned this
movie is kind of less on the horror end
of the giallo spectrum and more on the
crime and espionage end uh you know
there's kind of lots of double crosses
backhanded dealings everybody's a
suspect sneaky maneuvering it's all kind
of that kind of stuff going on it's a
very very convoluted plot and like i
said everybody has got some like [ __ ] to
hide now there are a handful of deaths
like i said i think there's only three
but really only one of them is all that
brutal and that one is actually like
pretty brutal like with the you know
slash and i think they even you know get
like a glasgow smile and everything uh
the first one is basically just a dude
getting his throat slit like not even
it's just kind of like he just goes
shoop and then you know like a shaving
cut and then the second one actually
takes place mostly off screen and we
only see the aftermath which like isn't
even bloody
um there is a lot of nudity though and
there's a lot of kind of stripper-esque
writhing and things like that so if
that's your bag then uh you'll probably
get your money's worth out of this one
um you know it's not the best yellow
i've ever seen but it's still pretty
solid uh it's not as hyper stylized or
as violent as some of the more kind of
like beloved genre staples obviously but
it's still like a pretty enjoyable
mystery with lots of twists and turns uh
and it never wears out its welcome it
actually had like a couple of twists and
turns in there that actually i really
didn't expect especially like one big
one like i said that i don't really want
to spoil um you know somebody that died
that you don't expect to die will just
like say that like that um but yeah so
this is absolutely worth watching uh if
you're you know like i said it's
probably not in the top tier but it's
like a tier or two down uh and if you
like just kind of like crime and mystery
type uh espionage type stuff then you'll
probably be into this one so that'll do
it for this flickers of fear continuing
on with giallo july and i will see you
guys on the next one bye